ladies and gentlemen I have very
exciting news there's a reason we
haven't uploaded in a while now I know
that reactions and reviews talking about
movies has been the driving force of the
real rejects but as of today we're
canceling all that John is now fired
we're gonna focus more on deep fake
videos from here on out because that's
what the people really want and that is
long-term sustainability
be taking you seriously right now guys
were so close to 700,000 subscribers why
did you subscribe and click that
notification bell New Mutants uh yay
they were delaying this film a lot but I
think after the critical and box-office
success of Dark Phoenix they were like
oh yeah put this out put the MC
properties do it
[Music]
[Applause]
so when your release thing
nice
Eliana Rasputin
[Music]
it's important we find how to your
collar so we can help you get better
the madhouse what
[Music]
setting up a franchise that's definitely
going to have multiple elements
everyone's gonna get a spinoff after
this movie we're gonna meet them all
individually two years since the teaser
trailer and they're still using that
same tribute so I get that creepy kids
choir going yeah of course
of course you need a good cover right
well uh yeah you know I I'd say overall
I'm glad this movie's coming out I think
that you know people put a lot of hard
work into this even if it's bad I'm
still glad it's getting released cuz
these people worked their asses off on
it Josh Boone and the whole cast
everyone involved I like in filmmaking
to cleaning wear because you need a lot
of chemicals so it's the what I'm
talking about is you know when you like
really clean like a house or an
apartment or even just your room and
then someone walks in there no one knows
how much work went into cleaning but
they might notice like a smudge on the
wall or something and that's what takes
their eye and I feel like they work
really hard somebody can work either way
just let it come out might as well and
there's a lot in the trailer that I do
like the metaphorical stuff of mutants
having the body horror element but also
factoring into their psychological
traumas I think is a concept worth
exploring within the x-men universe even
in fishes this one movie I think it's
worth exploring
well there's little taken aback weirdly
by the fact that the last bit said this
seemed like a superhero movie yeah we
really threw me for a loop like yeah
it's a part of the exponent world but I
thought they were just gonna solely
focus in on the horror elements and I
did hear some stuff and there's so much
I think the behind the scenes of this
movie is more fascinating to me and
interesting than the actual movie or so
far one day depending on how this movie
goes they'll make one of those
documentaries about the troubled
production of how this movie came to be
made in the first place like the island
of dr. Moreau or something like that
don't delay that documentary for three
years yeah yeah Josh Booher we cut a
bunch of time
you know but it'll still be pleased with
the cut I did hear that he did deliver
on making a horror movie and for some
reason that like scared Fox and they
didn't know what to do with it and I
wonder if they did do some like
superhero movie reshoots I don't know
like there's been so many things going
around about this movie that I have my
own theories that are not concrete at
all because so much talk has been going
on with this movie read about it it's
like we're gonna make it more horror now
we're gonna make it less now we're gonna
make it yaa and we're gonna do
everything with this what they got here
this doesn't look like an over
convoluted film it seems pretty simple
they're mutants being that they think
are being treated and help but really
they're being experimented upon and
trying to figure them out and then the
body horror elements are coming out of
them and then it's a escaped from an
asylum a story you know and I got some
creature monsters in there which look
cool and I mean they looked insanely
obscured in the lighting so I wonder if
when we do get to those monsters will be
like what the hell's going on yeah
they're all very very briefly teased dad
if anything I wonder yet how many of
these things were seeing our actual
monstrous villains or just
hallucinations that are being played on
from the kids subconscious yeah you know
and I'm his healer joy looks like a
standout you know she has the Russian
accent playing Ileana I mean just her
character introduction was everyone
else's introduction seem like an x-men
introduction her introduction was oh
yeah man I love it but you know I can't
say I'm confident I think it's a fine
trailer but you know it's it's been
delayed so much for a variety of reasons
I don't know what to believe at this
point
yeah if I hadn't heard all this news and
I just saw this trailer I think it was a
fine trailer I enjoyed it I liked still
the vibes that we're getting off of it I
like that we're going a full-on horror
route beating dr. strange to the punch
yeah and it's a good ensemble still like
it's the thing it doesn't appear in this
trailer like this has been as
troublesome as it has been and I don't
know I heard the Josh Boone is still
proud of the cut that he submitted for
this version so hopefully maybe it'll
actually be
right even though they've reshot more
than half the movie now well for some
reason the horror here doesn't look all
that scary I just feel like there's
gonna be a lot of like horror II things
happening but I don't think the movie
itself is gonna be all that terrifying I
don't get that vibe I hope it but yeah
especially now that Disney owns it and
they weren't happy with the cut that
they got I would imagine that some of
the MC use flavor may creep its way in
uh uh but that's again another
speculation based on another piece of
speculation that I read somewhere I'm
glad that this looks just decidedly
horror right now because that's the
freshest element that you can give yeah
I meant for this property well usually
the trailers dictate our energy and this
is what you got today guys well I don't
know did this trailer do it for you
are you guys excited this movie is
actually coming out do you think that
whatever version we're gonna get is
gonna be worth while do you think this
movie will actually come out pull up I
won't believe this movies out until I'm
sitting in the theater and it's playing
I only let it down until I have it on
blue and I'm watching it for the 17th
yeah you know what to do if you like you
know a channel subscribe click the
notification bell yada yada yada yeah
yeah yeah and I like to give a page from
the day shout out the first patron of
the day shout out of the New Year it's
gonna go to a man named Scuba Steve this
guy belongs in an insane asylum himself
this guy is a freak and a miscreant
always tagging things I was always
afraid to go to school cuz of people
like you when I was a child Scuba Steve
wrong side of the tracks
mutant quoting x-men 1
the school's child I did a terrible job
on the paraphrasing I saved your life
x-men yes shall I see you thanks buddy
you be well
you